we have a voicemail number at least for
now unless the audience says they want
to change that number is two one nine
two david p here is an idea from a
conservative who says the entire premise
of the show is wrong the entire focus of
my political philosophy is wrong and
this should basically just become a
right-wing show take a listen to this
well i really don't like to use this
language but i can't think of anything
else you're so foolish
i mean seriously you need to grow up and
you need to realize that the progressive
movement is not gonna help us do
anything you need to change your
allegiances and start supporting
conservative ideals because progressive
ideals will lead us to nothing but the
sewer actually you're gonna do you're
gonna run the country into the ground
people like you and people like all
these progressive idiots who think all
free this free that weapons free brother
and i figured you'd be old enough to
know that but obviously you're not right
you know my phone number is got the
bells call me back in organizing it's
not you know what i think you should go
on hannity show and tell him
face-to-face what you say to him behind
his back that's the best idea so far i
would love to go on hannity show and
talk to him face to face anytime he
wants to have me i'll be there there's
this funny idea that you sometimes hear
from the right that progressive ideas
are childish and once you grow up or
mature you sort of grow out of those
progressive ideas and it's so laughable
to me because number one it's based on
the false premise that people become
more conservative as they get older what
what the case is is that successively
younger generations are more to the left
for their entire lives there's not
actually evidence that individuals
become more conservative as they age
that i've seen willing to have my mind
changed on that but the idea of the
childish and immature ideas being on the
left the right believes in great part
that taxes are slavery or at least
should be almost completely eliminated
and that abortion is murder and that tax
cuts for the rich stimulate the economy
i have a hard time thinking of any
more childish and immature ideas than
those so those in glass houses
definitely shouldn't be throwing stones
and as far as calling this guy listen
I'm a little busy producing the show and
running an ad agency to call and have
off-air conversations with people but I
welcome you and in fact I invite you to
call in when we take live calls and I
would love to have a conversation with
you about the supposedly immature
progressive ideas on the bonus show
today a court has sided with the Trump
administration in a lawsuit over hotel
profits that is an important decision
actually Disneyland has experienced a
brawl and the case related to that brawl
has been sent to Orange County
prosecutors by the police department and
Pete Budaj edge has proposed a broad
plan to counter racial inequality and it
has some interesting things in it has
some ideas that I think are good one
some ideas that are a little bit more of
a question mark and we will be talking
about all of those ideas and many other
big ideas I'm going to have to be in
recovery mode all weekend actually from
so many high-level ideas on today's
bonus show get instant access to it by
becoming a member at join pakman.com or
by making a pledge on patreon at
patreon.com slash david pakman show